makes a difference does it okay
it does okay great so as you know the
simons institute is a a collaborative
research institute in theoretical
computer science
and uh it was funded in 2012
from uh
with a very generous grant from the
simons foundation and we run two
programs semester
and that has been since 2013
and you are one of the programs for this
semester and each program starts with a
bootcamp which is what we are doing
today and it has three more workshops
during um this semester
and brings even more people to institute
and this this time we're running it in a
hybrid form so we have some people in
the audience here
and there's a lot of people i think
remotely as well
um we have
uh long-term visitors a lot of fellows
and in particular this semester we're
very fortunate to have fellows not only
eight associated with each program but
also nsf fellows and simon's foundation
fellows and quantum uh
uh grant
uh
or quantum center type fellows so we
have two
um
pods
running assignments these days one is a
quantum part and one is a machine
learning pod in parallel with the two
programs that we're running
so as you know the goals of the boot
camp is that you will uh
get to know each other so sort of an
icebreaker both scientifically and
socially
and you get everyone on the same page as
to sort of the broad spectrum of the
field and what the program is about and
maybe have some archival
state-of-the-art uh
uh review so i want to thank the
organizers of the boot camp and uh
some logistics i guess um because of the
pandemic no food or drink i think inside
we have the food and drink outside
in the auditorium please everybody wear
a mask
i think the speakers have a choice also
wearing face shields i mean we've got a
lot of
masks up front so even though you don't
see them when you come in you can ask
for
you know either surgical mask or or
there's a lot of types of masks out
there
uh lunch on your own there are lockers
here in the hallway for use at lunchtime
the wi-fi access i think you know it's
cal visitor or eduroam
and everything is live streamed and
archived on our youtube channel
and a videographer is who is it there is
a meat there i haven't seen him in a
long time very sitting over there so if
you have problems you kind of wave him
in and he will help you
to uh with you know connecting computers
microphones
and i think i want to thank also kalani
who's where the event coordinator she's
outside she's outside okay
um and you can ask her if you have any
questions if you manage to recognize her
through the math you know good luck to
you so um welcome i mean i think this is
really very exciting and also program is
exciting
thanks very much jaffee um thanks also
to the um other uh folks who helped run
the simon institute peter and prasad
um
yeah thanks to you this this work this
whole you know the workshop and the
whole semester uh is even happening
um so we're very excited about that and
thanks as jeffy said also to the simon
staff um it's amazing how much they do
and
a little we then have to do as
organizers
um so thanks all of you and thanks also
to the rest of the organizers um
for making the semester uh happen
so i'll say a few words about what the
program is maybe very briefly and then
about what is this boot camp and what
you can hope to expect from it so this
program its title is computational
complexity of statistical inference
these are words that historically maybe
haven't particularly appeared together
in one phrase
and
the reason is because these separate
things have been studied separately so
statistics has been interested in how
much
statistical
resource do i need how much data or how
much signal do i need in order to solve
some problem and this has been studied
for close to a century for more than a
century now
um and a huge tradition of thought has
risen there
on the flip side computational
complexity has largely been interested
in how much computational resource so
especially time but also memory and
others do i need to solve some problem
um
typically
for instance in combinatorial
optimization all the information that
you need to solve the problem is there
in front of you and so you're not at all
sort of data constrained of course in
the modern machine learning and high
dimensional statistics problems both of
these issues are central and they
actually interplay in a really
interesting way
so this boot camp is aimed
to give some context and give
sort of an introduction to several of
the schools of thought that try to study
these questions
um so uh in the first part um today adam
clivens will tell us about a couple of
modern really interesting problems that
sit at this interface where both
computation and statistics are essential
um in the afternoon uh voz black will
tell us
about a sort of view from csps from
constraint satisfaction problems and
that's a setting that's relatively well
understood and for which many tools have
been developed and it can give us quite
a bit of insight into the behavior that
we might expect in these sorts of
problems
as we move later in the week
pulling low will tell us about
understanding statistical limits or
information theoretic limits to problems
if we don't understand those then we
don't even have a baseline for what you
can do without computational limits
um so that'll be quite important for us
and then procedural indra will tell us
about
restricted models of computation and how
to think about developing optimal
algorithms within certain classes for
certain problems of interest
and finally in the
second half or towards the end
luca trevorson will tell us about
average case complexity
so when i say computational complexity
hasn't been interested in statistics
problems there's sort of an exception um
because average case complexity and
it's very connected to many questions
that people have been interested in
cryptography is very much about problems
that are essentially you spent are
defined over data and so he'll tell us
some very interesting things in that
context and then finally we'll have
cindy rash and adrian montanari tell us
about amp and give us some insight into
this class of algorithms that's optimal
for a variety of problems and how should
we think about
whether amp is going to work or not work
and how do you analyze its performance
so with that i'll hand it off to adam
clivens
hey thanks guy i have a couple questions
for you before you go there
um how can you hear me first of all
no
yeah maybe it's our fault maybe it's our
oh i'm great on zooms
i'll wait for you guys to i was going to
ask well i guess the people in the
auditorium can't hear me but maybe i'll
type it
oh
guy can you can you guys can you guys
hear me yet in the auditorium
yeah
okay so how are we going to handle
questions
from the in-person audience they'll just
speak up i mean that would be great i
think we can try that
are they okay
that's fine that's fine that's fine with
me i mean if they want to come to the
podium that's also fine
there's a bike right
now i mean if you can hear us then
presumably everybody
can hear who's ever speaking up as well
okay i i can sort of hear you so you
know speak loudly if you have a question
if you don't mind
okay
well anyway
thanks to the simons institute for
hosting this
program and thanks to the i am one of
the organizers but my co-organizers
asked me to give this talk and so thanks
for inviting me and
um thanks to peter and shafi for all the
great programs that they've been
organizing
over the last couple of years and i also
want to um thanks to my colleagues um
serbi gowell satan chen fred kohler
rugby mecca for feedback on this talk
and i'm really excited to be here it's
going to be a great program and i'm
i'm thrilled to to kick off the boot
camp
so as as guy mentioned i'm going to talk
about some
problems from an algorithmic perspective
that will touch upon sort of sample
complexity and these computational
statistical gaps and i've titled
two of these two talks in search of new
algorithms and hopefully at the end of
the two talks you'll understand why in
the first part of the talk is all about
neural networks
i'm adam clivens from the university of
texas at austin
so the question that i've really been
interested in for the last couple of
years are
by the way can you see my oh wait you
don't have my slides i see okay
that's a problem
just a sec
okay can you see that now
okay great yeah so
excellent so the the question that i've
been really interested in for the last
couple of years is
um what are the most powerful algorithms
for learning neural networks or for
performing supervised learning
um
[Music]
on deep networks
and uh you know the current best
algorithm that we have
is back propagation or gradient descent
i'm sure you're all familiar with it but
a question that i like to ask people is
you know do you think this will be the
algorithm that will be running in 50
years
in order to train
neural networks um and i think it's a
really important question supervised
learning is sort of the engine that
drives a lot of applications in machine
learning
and also i think it's a little bit this
question of what algorithms are we
actually using to train our neural
networks to perform deep learning
i think it's a little bit under the
radar we've seen how important it is to
have more data and to have more compute
but you know a really um in-depth
investigation of what are the best sort
of algorithms that we have for training
our networks you know what are some
interesting new algorithmic tools with
provably efficient guarantees that we
can develop i i don't think it's been
studied as much and i think it has the
potential for great impact we've seen
that even small
improvements on gradient descent or back
propagation can have really important
applications so
so this is sort of my my big question
and the analogy that i like to make is
one with sort of linear programming and
the simplex method
um i mean it was it's been known for
decades that the simplex method works
really well in practice to solve linear
programs
but only in the last say you know 10 or
15 years
i think has the community sort of
decided that we understand the
complexity of the simplex method pretty
well and this is this um important and
seminal smooth analysis paper by dan
spielman and chiang wan tang that i'm
referring to
so it took a very long time before i
think we had a satisfactory theoretical
understanding of why the simplex method
worked so well in practice
and along with the simplex method if you
think about solving linear programs or
convex programs we have a super
interesting toolkit of methods for
convex programming known as interior
point methods
they've been very influential they've
had a lot of applications and so it's
really great that the simplex method has
this sort of complementary toolbox
of powerful provably efficient
algorithms
it's a real success
story in theoretical computer science
and optimization
so i like to think of gradient descent
or sgd or back propagation as sort of a
modern day simplex method
it works really well in practice it's
also very difficult to analyze i i don't
think we still have a satisfactory
understanding or explanation of why it
works so well in practice
and even more to the point i don't think
that we have a complementary toolbox of
algorithms or at least a rich
complementary toolbox of algorithms for
gradient descent for training neural
networks um and so i i really want to
focus on more this one i mean i think
understanding gradient descent and sgd
is a super important research question
and i'm very interested in it this talk
is going to sort of ask the question
again to ask you to think about you know
what are some provably efficient
algorithms that we could develop in the
coming years and decades to kind of
complement
gradient descent i mean who knows maybe
we're leaving a lot on the table by not
exploring this question
as thoroughly as we should
so the goal of this boot camp talk is
going to be to sort of survey the state
of the art for provably efficient
algorithms for learning one hidden layer
neural networks
and then i'm going to go i'm going to
give you some examples of how you can
actually probably go beyond gradient
descent for some of these tasks
so that'll be the first part of the talk
then in the second part of the talk i'll
talk about similar problem similar sort
of a similar sort of agenda for
graphical models and hopefully i'll be
able to tie both of these topics
together
and so as i mentioned earlier if you're
in the physical audience and you want to
ask a question please just speak loudly
and if you're in the
uh i guess i don't know how we're doing
questions oh we're using the chat
interface the webinar the q and a so
hopefully someone will monitor that and
at least let me know
if you have questions i'm happy to take
lots of questions
so i have a question
just about yours is that shafi yeah it's
just about your analogy
oh hi shopping
uh about your analogy the linear
programming is in polynomial time
uh whereas learning one layer neural
network is in the worst case right we
know it's uh
yes
there's a difference but just
so actually it depends on what you mean
by hard i mean did you say it's np hard
for many many years ago yeah i'll get to
that so it's np hard but in a very
restricted model and then kind of the
point of this talk is going to be to
show you how to circumvent a lot of
those hardness results
okay so
let me just define the learning model
for you the learner is going to receive
iid examples i y i drawn from some
distribution and typically we'll work in
the noiseless case although we can talk
about noise models a little bit i'm
happy to take questions on that where we
have some label y and it's equal to c of
x
for some concept in some function class
and you can think of this function class
for most of today although at the end
we'll go into deeper networks as uh
one layer nets
and then the goal this is sort of the
regression problem the goal is going to
be to output a hypothesis h
such that the expected square loss of h
when i see new examples that i haven't
seen before is bounded by epsilon times
the expected value of y squared
so one thing immediately to notice is
that and i'll emphasize this again as we
go through the talk i'm really
interested in the complexity of
outputting a hypothesis that has small
test error not necessarily small
training error so we want to do
something more than small training error
we want to get small test error and this
is often referred to as simply pack
learning
more recently this has been referred to
as sort of the student teacher model of
learning neural networks i'll be using
these terms interchangeably and the
reason why i'm calling this a regression
problem is that we're looking at square
loss here
okay and
we could also look at classification
problems and the way i like to think
about classification problems is again
you're given x i y i drawn from some
distribution
and the y will now be a boolean value
zero and one
but the conditional mean function
is still real valued so this c of x
still could be a real valued
network
but the conditional mean function so the
expected value of y given an input x is
going to be equal to c of x
and then our goal will be again to
output a hypothesis with small test
error what does that mean in the
classification setting it just means
that when i draw a new example x y the
probability that it disagrees with the
boolean label is now at most epsilon and
again this is some this is
classification
okay so typically until we get sort of
to the end of this first hour i'm going
to be thinking about this function class
as one layer neural networks
and um the output y
is going to be so what is a one layer
neural network it's a linear combination
of activations so these lambda i's are
the coefficients for these activations
this is sigma here
um and could be your favorite activation
like tange or sigmoid for most of today
i will be considering the very popular
relu activation
which just equals max
of z
and zero
and these
these w i's are going to be our hidden
weight vectors
and so um the main sort of
distributional assumption i'll be taking
throughout this hour and this is part of
the reason why um
the np hardness results that shafi
mentioned are not going to apply
is that i'm going to assume that the
distribution the marginal distribution
on x is equal to just a spherical
gaussian
okay so it's sort of the simplest setup
that you could imagine you have a lot of
information about what the marginal
distribution on x looks like it's a
spherical gaussian and i'm just taking a
linear combination of activations um and
they're they're sort of two remember in
in learning we just want to come up with
a hypothesis that has small square loss
with respect to future examples so i
don't necessarily need to really fully
identify these parameters
the w i's and the lambda i's if you can
do that that's great it's called
parameter recovery that's stronger than
what you know we're interested in here
which is just going to be to achieve
small test loss with some efficient
algorithm
okay and i'm calling this the canonical
setup because
um there are dozens of papers that
appear on the archive every year that
study this exact problem with the
marginal distribution being gaussian
and
i used to sort of field a lot of
objections about the fact that i'm that
i'm taking this assumption that d of x
is gaussian
um i've really relaxed
i've chilled out about it in in large
part well for a couple for a couple of
reasons
one is that it as you'll see as we go
through the talk it's it's a really
great assumption to sort of clarify
what's hard and where we can make new
algorithm algorithmic progress it also
rules out a bunch of np hardness results
but another reason for liking this
gaussian assumption is um you know the
power of generative models so if you
believe
that generative models
really do represent you know can form
representations of images or faces you
know
as we've seen recently um you know the
way they work is that there's some
gaussian seed and then you have a a very
complicated neural network or deep net
and it has it produces these sort of
you know images that look very very
realistic
and you can imagine that you want to do
downstream classification on these
images that are output by a generative
model
well if you compose the generative model
with the neural network that's doing the
object classification
then you really do start from a gaussian
distribution and you end up with some
classification problem on a downstream
task so i actually think that the
gaussian distribution
if you're interested in deep networks is
a very reasonable and interesting
assumption
okay and this is sort of a technical
slide don't get too worried about it but
since we're working in gaussian space
you know we'll be looking at these
functions that are that are bounded in
some sense that they're square
integrable and we have a natural
associated inner product which is just
uh for two functions f and g which is
just the integral of f and g times uh
the gaussian distribution
and then if you work in this space it's
very well known in classical that the
hermit polynomials form a basis for this
oh
uh okay
or more that they didn't refresh
when you switched slide
they're there now we're there yeah
all right i think there was just some
lag well it's good it was a technical
side you didn't really need to pay
attention to anything
but um
yeah these these hermit polynomials form
a basis and uh you can take the inner
product of a function with with the
k-thermite polynomial and you get the
k-thermite coefficient so these are the
fourier coefficients of hermit
coefficients in the space this is just
so the future if i refer to hermit
coefficients you know what i'm talking
about
okay um so let's talk about sample
complexity for just a second and i think
it's important to point out that by any
measure this problem is information
theoretically easier easy
so for example if you consider the
ratamacre complexity of these function
classes or the vc dimension or if you do
something really naive and you just
count the number of parameters that that
are involved in these function classes
then we know that the sample complexity
for learning these
uh one layer neural networks or even
deeper neural networks is polynomial in
all of the relevant parameters so the
relevant parameters here are
oops d
uh
k the number of hidden units
uh one over epsilon that's the accuracy
parameter
and um you know what we really wanted is
efficient runtime and
we may not be able to achieve polynomial
time in all of these parameters but at a
minimum we'd like to do something that's
polynomial in the dimension
um or at least sub-exponential in the
dimension
and the reason for that is that as i
said we're sort of interested in coming
up with new algorithms
and if you allow me to run in time
exponential in the dimension
then i can form sort of a net
of neural networks i can use brute force
search to find a neural network
that
you know fits my training set very well
and i can just output that neural
network
uh that's not the most exciting
algorithm um
and and certainly
it will be difficult to implement so we
want to try and avoid brute force search
and the way to sort of enforce that
you're avoiding brute force search is
going to be to at the very least require
some sub-exponential in the dimension
type performance
and i also think it's sort of
instructive to ask you know what happens
if p equals np
again then learning is easy
why is that well there's some ground
truth function from the function class
that i would like to learn
i'm going to take a large but still
polynomial size training set as i
mentioned uh you can get away with
polynomial size complexity and all of
the relevant parameters here
and then i'll just guess a one layer say
resu network of smaller size
that has small square loss on the
training set
and because i'm i've chosen a large
enough but still polynomial size
training set and i've guessed a
one-layer neural network that's smaller
than the size of the training set you
can prove via standard generalization
bounds that this network will have small
square loss on future test examples
okay so here's sort of an easy
observation if we want to get an
algorithm that has running time that's
sub-exponential in the dimension
we could just remember that these one
hidden layer neural networks
uh really are
juntas in the sense that they only
depend
on the subspace that's spanned by these
weight vectors these w i's
okay and they're only k of them
so if you tell me what the subspace is
that's spanned by these k hidden weight
vectors
um if you were to actually give me that
subspace then it would be some k
dimensional subspace again spanned by
these hidden weight vectors
and then i could do
i could i could do brute force search in
this
smaller dimensional space
and since k is a separate parameter from
d
well then at least for small k i'm doing
something
non-trivial so kind of the first
non-trivial question you might ask about
learning these function classes
is
can you find the relevant subspace
that's spanned by the hidden weight
vectors can you do this um efficiently
or at least uh not pay exponential and
dimension in order to find this subspace
just can we find the subspace
i don't know why why small k like from
from a modeling perspective
like is it just a choice to get yourself
some tractable setting you can think
about or is there like some real world
reason that small k makes sense
uh well
because we don't know how to do it i
mean
of course we would like polynomial in k
uh but at least this was get would get
us 2 to the k
uh or something like 2 to the k and that
would be much much much better than you
know 2 to the d
um
and hopefully that you know there's some
interesting algorithm that that's
involved to kind of find this the
subspace so i i guess from a
um
certainly in practice there you know
lots of dimensionality reduction
reduction techniques and so i think it's
you know still interesting to try and
understand you know can we find
um you know the low dimensional manifold
that our data is living on so
well
is that sam hopkins that's me okay
so we assume that the
lambda i's uh in in this combinat
combination for right now let's assume
that they're positive
um then there is there you know let me
start off by telling you kind of one
simple thing that you can do and this
was actually in a very recent i think
2020 paper
of dieca nicholas cain cantonus and
zerifus
and what you can do
is you can form this matrix it looks
like a pca matrix i'm calling a
and it's the expectation of y the label
times x x transpose minus the identity
so it's um
sort of like covariance matrix
and what they proved and this was known
for other activations for all
differentiable activations as i'll
mention in the future although i don't i
think they were
the first to actually write this down
for the relu activation
you can prove that this matrix if you
look at its expectation is actually
equal to some constant times the sum of
outer products
w i w i transpose
uh
times lambda i's
okay so it gives you this nice outer
product um
decomposition of the weight vectors just
they just sort of pop out it's uh not a
difficult proof
and if you take sufficiently many
samples
to get an estimate of this expectation
then you can just because the lambda i's
are positive
we can apply
the the svd algorithm to this matrix
and out pops the hidden weight vector
sorry the then weight vectors don't
necessarily pop out but the subspace um
spanning
uh the subspace the relevant subspace
sort of pops out here i'll find a basis
for my relevant subspace
and if you take enough examples you have
to be careful that you're getting a good
enough approximation to this relevant
subspace because we have to just
approximate this expectation but you end
up getting an algorithm with running
time uh roughly uh k over epsilon
to the k squared
and then this wasn't known so so um
there's also a polynomial in d here
but this wasn't known so so it's
interesting
even for k equals a constant number of
hidden units uh this so for k equals the
constant number of hidden units this
gives you a polynomial time algorithm
and that wasn't known wait why does it
become exponential in k that's because
you're going to do brute force search in
the k-dimensional subspace yes
okay
and um i recently saw
dan kane give a talk about this
where uh they gave a very powerful
generalization of this result
um and i really like the way he
explained it so i'm just sort of going
to pair his explanation so another way
to to think about this is that again we
have this matrix a
uh which is equal to the sum of outer
products
and if we could take a vector v and just
look at the quantity v transpose a v
um it's easy to see that this is equal
to the sum
of lambda i v inner product w i squared
okay and this is going to be equal to
zero
if and only if v inner product w i is
equal to zero
for all the i's
okay so this means that these that
satisfy this equality uh form a subspace
of co-dimension k
and um there's a very nice uh recent
2021 paper of um of elias and dan
that so this is sort of what happens
when you know they look they view this
as like a degree two polynomial
um and they generalize this to higher
degrees so they look at higher order
moments
oh
okay
sorry this is telling me this is from
2020 sorry
uh so they look at higher order moments
and the way that you do that is you can
you know it turns out if you look at the
expectation of uh y
you know uh with x
tensored to higher powers
you can compute polynomials of the form
sum lambda i q of w i so imagine q is a
degree 2d polynomial
in particular i can form a polynomial
a capital q that takes in as input p
and outputs the sum from i equals 1 to k
of lambda i p squared of wi
just as as we did before with the svd
and here this polynomial q of p is equal
to zero if and only if this polynomial
of your hidden weight vector is equal to
zero for all
eyes and what you can prove is that the
dimension of this variety is at most d
times k to the one over d
and in this paper
they have a a very non-trivial
construction of a net for this variety
uh but it is an efficient
algorithm to construct a net for this
for this space
and if you set all the parameters
correctly they actually end up getting
an algorithm that runs in quasi-quasi
polynomial time so they improve that k
over epsilon to the k squared
down to k over epsilon uh raised to the
log squared k power
and again there's a
polynomial in d here
okay so sort of also to answer sam's
question it's useful to think about this
space problem because it can uh lead to
more efficient algorithms we didn't get
a polynomial time algorithm here we got
a quasipot they achieve a
quasi-polynomial time algorithm but a
very nice result in there this approach
also applies to a lot of different
models of latent variables including
mixture models
um yeah if you like maybe five
five to ten years ago there were all
these works on length variable models
via intensity composition where you
didn't have to do like
high degree polynomials you would just
do like degree three like it's like go
from sp i'm gonna talk i'm gonna talk
about those in just a second okay
okay so the so this is a very nice
result the main drawback is that we had
to assume that these lambda i's were
positive
um
and so i guess
sort of sam uh you're leading into this
slide you know can we do something else
um
and there's something else that we can
do
is something called um
you know we can apply algorithms for
tensor decomposition
okay so
this uh so there's a different algorithm
that we can apply and this was a result
i think that dates back to 2015 by um
jansmen segni and
anan kumar
and again recall that we have some
cfx some one hidden layer neural network
that we're trying to learn here
and
and actually i want to assume that the
activation now is continuous and
differentiable so it's not going to be
able to handle uh well value per se the
original works couldn't
handle values but you can get around
that
and the main tool for analyzing or
applying some of these tensor methods
is
stein's lemma
and this limit basically says that if
you have any
differentiable function c and you tensor
it with x
then you get the expectation of the
gradient of c with respect to x so it's
a nice identity
and as you keep tensoring up uh powers
of x
then you get more and more you take more
and more gradients of the function that
you're trying to learn
and so as we just saw
if you tensor one more time you get the
expectation roughly of
wi
wi transpose
and if you again tensor one more time
then you'll get the expectation
of
something times
uh wi tensored to the third power
and the reason why these hidden weight
vectors keep kind of popping out to
popping out to higher powers is that you
keep applying the chain rule as you're
differentiating
and this s3 is something called the
score function
and in gaussian spaces is actually equal
to the polynomial
but the main idea here is that instead
of looking at expectation of y x x
transpose
we can actually
uh look at expectation of y
well
something like x tensor to third power
and then
that actually gives us some expression
that involves third powers of the weight
vectors
and the bottom line is that um
by looking at expectation of y
times higher order tensors of tensor
powers of x you actually get access
to these linear combinations of higher
order powered tensors of the weight
vectors
and then you can apply these very
powerful tensor decomposition algorithms
for example we could apply
yen rich's algorithm uh to actually
recover
uh to within epsilon
so we could actually do parameter
recovered so once we have this linear
combination of higher order powers of
these weight vectors you can apply a
tensor decomposition algorithm and you
can actually find
very good approximations to these wi's
and if you apply for example yenrich's
algorithm what you need
is that the wis are all linearly
independent
and because we had an expectation we had
to
sample
and we need to sample enough to make
sure that our wi's actually look
linearly independent if they are indeed
linearly independent
and when you do sampling
what you end up paying
is the smallest singular value
of all of these weight vectors
stacked as a matrix so for example if my
hidden weight vectors are very very
close in angular distance
then i'm going to pay a lot in sample
complexity it makes sense if the hidden
weight vectors are very close to angular
distance then i need to take many
samples in order to distinguish them and
these tensor decomposition algorithms
actually will distinguish them they'll
give me
the parameter recovery
okay so the so these algorithms are
great
um
but the the drawback
yeah i guess you know the main drawback
of these algorithms so they can handle
lambda i's
that are no longer necessarily positive
so we don't have to have positive linear
combinations of neural networks but we
do pay in terms of this condition number
of this matrix so we pay if these weight
vectors are very close in angular
distance or even worse if this matrix is
singular
then we're out of luck so sort of
you can't handle a number of hidden
vectors k that's more than the dimension
of your space
but this approach has still had many
interesting applications there's been a
lot of related work
[Music]
so for example uh there's this very nice
paper of zhang jane bartlett and dylan
from a couple of years ago
that used these tensor decomposition
algorithms to come up with a solution
for the one himalayan neural network
case for epsilon being a constant
so they get sort of a warm start
and then you run gradient descent
to come up with a very accurate
hypothesis and they show that you get
logarithmic convergence once you have
sort of a warm start
there's a nice paper by
bakshi jerome and woodruff that combine
tensor decomposition techniques with
independent component analysis to come
up with
some incomparable results for learning
one hidden layer neural networks
and there was a very very recent paper
uh of awasti tang and vijaya raghavan
that can handle the case when these relu
networks have non-zero bias
um
uh and also
uh can handle sort of a smooth analysis
setting of learning one hidden layer
neural networks
but all of these works
pay
in terms of the condition number
of that matrix
where you stack
the hidden weight vectors
okay so that's one drawback of all these
of all these results
okay so to summarize
for the techniques that i've described
thus far you either need to assume that
the lambda eyes are positive or that the
wi's are well conditioned
and you know we'd really like to just
solve one layer uh come up with
algorithms for one layer in neural
networks and and you know maybe this
problem is computationally hard as as
shafi sort of uh mentioned and alluded
to at the beginning of this
lecture and i think
um conventional wisdom you know that
what i feel is conventional wisdom on
hardness results for learning these
neural networks
is
um
as shafi mentioned that they're np hard
that you can come up with these
simple training sets
such that finding very simple neural
networks that have low air with respect
to these training sets
um is is very difficult and why is that
well
over the years we figure out we've you
know the field has figured out ways of
encoding
either hard combinatorial optimization
problems or hard cryptographic problems
um
and one complaint about this about these
results has been sort of oh well
you know the examples that you're
looking at here are very discreet and
boolean and they're not
they don't really occur in practice
they're very artificial
and so i i think that um as the years
went on and people kept proving more and
more sort of crypto hardness results or
np hardness results people started to
tire of these results a little bit
because they felt that they were a
little bit detached
from um
you know some of the data sets that we
were seeing in practice
and and some of the constructions might
have seemed you know a little bit
contrived although i personally like all
of these results very much and i
actually think they're very important
so one result that i want to
mention
[Music]
is a result that i had with my graduate
students
and carmelkar and what we proved is that
there's actually something for more
fundamental going on
than sort of encoding hard combinatory
optimization problems or hard
cryptographic problems there are more
fundamental barriers for coming up with
efficient algorithms for learning when
they are known networks and what we
proved is the hardest result for
gradient descent that is to say even if
the marginal distribution on your points
is gaussian
and if you have any non-polynomial
activation so
sigma weight or value doesn't matter
then unconditionally
we can prove that gradient descent
cannot achieve a polynomial in the
dimension or
run time
to learn one hidden layer neural
networks
okay and this rules out a lot of popular
approaches for coming up with
um
over param for learning via over
parameter over parameterization such as
the neural tangent kernel approach or
the mean field approach you can just
prove that
they can't learn the class of one hidden
layered neural networks
so a lot of people ask me after i
mentioned that
you know this i don't understand what
you're saying this is very confusing you
know there are a lot of recent results
showing that
about the neural tangent kernel showing
that the the ntk can actually solve one
hidden layer of neural networks if the
marginal distribution is gaussian
and that's not quite right actually the
main result of say the neural tangent
kernel is to show that if you over
parameterize a neural network and you
run
a stochastic gradient descent on it then
you'll get small training error
but if you want to prove that the
neural network that you get after
performing sgd on this training set
actually has small test loss
then you need to take further
assignments
and
you know the results that i'm about to
tell you about explain exactly why you
need to take further assumptions there's
just no way of proving that you can get
small test loss
for this for this class
because we can prove unconditionally
it's not possible
okay so more generally we're going to
prove two different types
of lower bounds
um one is a lower bound for
something called um correlational
statistic statistical queries csq
and another is a lower bound for sq
which is sort of general statistical
queries and these are probably two
models that'll pop up in other talks uh
during this boot camp
so in the csq model
what am i
you know i so i need to i need to force
the learner to work in some model so
that i can prove a lower bound against
that model and in this model in the csq
model the learner is going to pick some
function phi of x
and then receive the following statistic
it will receive the expectation of phi
of x times y
plus or minus some
tolerance parameter tau
and in the sq model
the learner can do something more
powerful
the learner can pick a query function
phi of x y
and received just the expectation of x y
five x y plus or minus now so the
restriction in the csq model is really
that y
has to be multiplied by phi of x your
query function so it's a very specific
class of queries
but one nice thing is that it's easy to
see
that gradient descent
falls into this class of csq queries and
so any lower bound that you prove for
csq is going to apply to gradient design
and so what we'll prove or what you can
prove is that there's a csq lower bound
for learning one hidden layer neural
networks
it turns out in order to prove
a lower bound in this csq model
it suffices to find a family of
one-layer
neural networks or one-layer relu
networks that are almost pairwise
orthogonal that is to say find a family
of one layer neural networks
such that for every two functions f1 and
f2 the expectation of f1 times f2
is at most epsilon
and if you had discrete distributions so
if we if our domain was the boolean
hypercube
then this
construction is pretty easy you can just
compute parity functions but we can't do
that here because the marginal
distribution is gaussian so that makes
the situation a little bit more
challenging
okay so let me just flash the
construction here on this slide so you
can pick any as i said non-polynomial
activation
and i'm going to fix some subset s
of d of size k
and then i'll have this function g sub s
that looks at the sum over all weight
vectors in minus 1 1 to the k
and it outputs some
coefficient plus 1 or minus 1 which is
equal to the parity of w
times phi of w inner product xs over
root k so the reason why i'm showing you
this construction is just to show you
that it's relatively simple
and it's easy to see
that the size of this family is roughly
d to the k because s is a subset of d uh
1 through d of size at most k
and if i choose k
to be log d then you can see that the
number of um
uh hidden units
in every one of these functions is the
most polynomial in d because it's going
to be 2 to the log d so each
element of my function family here is
actually polynomial size but i have
i'll have a d to the log d i'll have a
you know super polynomial number of uh
functions in this family
and these are the functions that will
prove a pairwise orthogonal so now you
might be saying oh look you're encoding
parity here with these functions but i'm
actually not this is just a coefficient
it's plus one or minus one
so i'm taking many
positive and negative combinations of
this activation but i'm not encoding the
parity function
um and to prove this you just need this
simple fact
that if you apply
uh
a vector z component wise to f
that the parity of z sort of pops out
you can pull it out of the function
and so if you want to prove that the
expectation of f of s times f of t is
equal to zero
because x is from a symmetric
distribution this is the same as
choosing z
at random and then looking at the
expectation
and then i can pull out
the parity of z
and then this is the two different
parity functions and their expectation
for random z
is going to be zero
so this zeros out the entire uh this
shows that they're they're orthogonal so
i wrote down this proof just to show you
that it's it's not a very difficult
proof
now the the actually the trickier part
is to show that this family of functions
is non-zero but you can do it with an
appropriate hermet expansion and this
just gives you your csq lower bound
independently from that same paper that
i mentioned a couple of slides ago uh
diaconicalis cane contonus and zerifus
they actually have a more sophisticated
construction and they get an exponential
lower bound for one hidden layer neural
networks we got a quasi-polynomial bound
okay
sorry about that
and um there's also a hardness result
a very recent hardness result due to
daniel lee and vardy
that shows um if crypto hardness for
learning depth three neural networks
with large biases even if the marginal
distribution is gaussian
okay so
they don't get crypto hardness for depth
two uh that's another reason to study
sort of one hidden layer neural networks
it seems to avoid a lot of these
hardness results
um so it turns out that this csq model
is actually very different from the sq
model for real value functions so
we can obtain csq lower bounds for one
hidden layer neural networks for
gradient descent
if you want to obtain the full sq lower
bound then
you need to do
you need to look at the classification
problem so you need to let me take my
one-hand layer in your network and run
it through a soft max and do
classification if you let me do that
then you can prove the general sq lower
bounds
and we actually ran some experiments
here um so we took this hard family of
one hidden layer of neural networks
and what you see when you run express
what we did was we took we over
parameterized neural network we ran sgd
on it
and the red line in these plots is the
training loss which as you can see goes
to zero very quickly
but the blue dashed line is the test
loss
and
as you can see that continues to stay
a large so
even though you're running gradient
descent on an over-parameterized network
and even though the training loss is
very small the test loss just stays very
large
okay so to summarize no csq algorithm
can learn one hidden layer neural
networks in polynomial time that's what
we proved
now without all the algorithms that i
mentioned at the very beginning of this
talk it turns out that they're all csq
algorithms
why is that well they look at the
expectation of y times something as we
said in the csq model the queries that
the learner gets to make have to be of
the form y times some query function
so
it was either y times x x transpose or y
times
x taken to somehow some higher order
power these are all csq algorithms and
that's why they have to pay either you
know they require either sort of
positivity of the coefficients
or bound on the condition number of the
weight vectors these assumptions you
know what this lower bound that i just
mentioned shows that these assumptions
are necessary for these class of
algorithms and you know we're in search
of new algorithms so the question is you
know can we go beyond
the csq
model
um
so
yeah another good question so this is
the is the hardness like um
the fact that like uh
constant order moment based algorithms
are csq
um
is the hardness sort of hiding in the
tolerance here like okay here's the
here's the right question sorry if i
give you those moment tensors exactly
like forget the tolerance parameters and
the queries
um are the
can you do learning is the model is it
identifiable like are these are these
identifiable from i don't know tenth
order moments
um
yeah that's a good question like is it
hiding in the tolerance that's what i'm
what i'm asking
i think the general csq that is true
that it's hiding in the tall way because
you know if you don't put the constraint
then you can just create the answer bit
by bit but for moments i think even
polynomial accuracy is not
i think those moment sensors are
literally zero for those controllers
yeah exactly
yeah i see okay the point is that you
can see you can make a large family of
uh one layer next and the all the
elements of zero votes are zero so
right and you can estimate them pretty
well
i mean i mean the one caveat to that is
that you know if
if the i mean you do lose this issue
about
you know the condition i mean the reason
why the condition number sort of comes
in is that you need these sampling
issues in order to get robust linear
independence when you want to apply
these tensor decomposition algorithms so
you will that issue will sort of go away
to some extent but you still will need
like linearly linearly linear
independence of the weight vectors
and your construction does not have
linearly independent weight vectors
right like there should be linear
dependencies
oh they are oh yes they are linear
dependencies absolutely
yeah
okay
good question
okay so
so we have these lower bounds for the
the csq setting and we want to move
beyond the csq setting can we move
beyond the csq setting
so i want to go back to this problem of
finding the subspace spanned by your
hidden weight factors i mean again
that's sort of the first task that we
need to solve in order to have any hope
of doing some you know non-trivial uh
learning
and um so
in order to go beyond sort of the csq
setting
instead of looking at the expectation of
y times
uh say x x transpose we're going to look
at
we're going to come up with algorithms
that actually sort of uh choose
you know come up with some function phi
of y so we're not just going to look at
expectation of y times something we're
going to look at the expectation of five
y times maybe that gives us some
additional creativity that we can use to
find the relevant subspace and indeed it
does
so one thing to notice
is that um so i'm calling v here capital
v the subspace the relevant subspace
spanned by these hidden weight vectors
and
for any vector u that's in the the
orthogonal complement of v if i look at
u
of m u transpose so m is this matrix
right here
you'll get it's the expectation of phi
times the projection of
of v of x into the relevant subspace
times u uh inner product x squared minus
1. this is what this
expansion turns into and then right here
we'll use gaussianity
to split this expectation into a product
of two expectations
uh that's because if the vectors are
orthogonal then as random variables
they're independent
so i'll get the expectation of phi of
the projection of v
of x onto v times the expectation of u
inner product x squared minus one
this term is zero and so i get that the
expectation is zero so what does this
mean well this is at least a nice
starting point it tells us
that
vectors
that are in the kernel of this matrix
are actually in the irrelevant subspace
okay so
so that's a good starting point and what
we could hope uh is that if we look at
sort of the singular value decomposition
of m that there will be at least one
vector that's in the relevant subspace
that we're trying to find
and that's kind of precisely what we're
going to do
so um
what should be our choice of phi here
obviously we don't want to choose phi to
be the identity function but it turns
out that we're going to choose phi of y
to be the indicator function
that y is at least some value tau
and this is this
type choice of phi was used in a prior
work by setan chen and regu mecca
for the case when you were learning
polynomials of inner products of hidden
weight vectors
here we're looking at a one layer value
network of weight vectors so it's sort
of a significant it turns out to be a a
significantly
uh different setting
than the polynomial setting but so but
this is going to be the key choice of
phi here and this is how we're going to
evade the cs2 lower bounds
okay and this leads me to sort of the
main positive result this is going to be
the main example of an algorithm that
can learn one hidden layer neural
networks the gradient descent or any csq
algorithm cannot
and uh this is from a recent paper
learning deep braille networks is
fixed parameter tractable uh again with
uh satan chan and raghu mecca
and this time
we're going to look at deep networks not
just one hidden layer neural networks so
i'm going to be able to take my one
hidden layer neural network and compose
it with many different
weight matrices and many different and
several compositions of of the
activation function and here i still
want to find some function g
whose square loss is less than or equal
to epsilon
and what we're going for unfortunately
we're not able to get polynomial
polynomial time algorithm in all of the
relevant parameters
but this algorithm will at least be a
fixed polynomial in the ambient
dimension d an exponential
in the parameters of the network
and this is the first positive result of
any sort for learning value networks of
depth greater than two
with respect to the gaussian density
even when all of those parameters that
i'll mention of the network were held
constant no subux special time algorithm
was known
and it's the first example of a class of
deep nets that can be efficiently
learned by an algorithm and provably not
by gradient descent
and
just to tell you what
the quantitative result actually is
the important part the network
parameters here that i'm talking about
are going to be the depth
of the lipschitz constant the size of
the network
um and potentially the spectral norm of
all of those weight matrices
and the sample complexity of our
algorithm is going to be
roughly linear in the dimension
times some exponential function of all
of these parameters
and the running time will be quadratic
again times some exponential function in
all of these parameters i don't think
it's so important what the explosive um
function is what's more important is
that we're actually getting a fixed
polynomial uh dependence for the sample
complexity and the running time in the
dimension
it turns out that this lipschitz
parameter is crucial we actually have
you can prove that you actually have to
depend on the lipschitz parameter in
some way
okay so again instead of forming that
matrix um
so just looking at the time here i think
i'm going to explain
uh this result maybe i'll stop
um and then we'll continue after the
break
um so we'll form this matrix which is
like a filtered covariance matrix it's
the expectation of the indicator
function
that the the label y is greater than
some tolerance tau
times xx transpose minus the identity so
we sort of we call this filtered pca
because it's zeroing out a bunch of
x's
for which the label is not sufficiently
large
what we'd like to prove is that when you
take the trace inner product
of the projection into the relevant
dimension v
with this filtered pca matrix m sub tau
that when you look at its singular value
decomposition
that the relevant vectors spanning this
space actually appear that's what we'd
like to prove
so we'd like to prove a lower bound on
the trace inner product of the
projection into the relevant subspace
times this matrix m tau
and if you do a little calculation
when you take the trace inner product
with the projection into the relevant
subspace pi of v
you get this expression the expectation
that the indicator is greater than tau
times
the norm of x projected into the
relevant subspace squared minus k
and what we'd like to do is pick this
threshold appropriately
you can think of tau as being roughly
root 2k although we'll talk about it
more later but you want to pick tau
appropriately so that if y is
sufficiently large
then the projection
the norm of the projection of x into the
relevant subspace is sufficiently large
so as the output values of my relu
network are getting larger and larger
i'm just hoping that the projection of x
into the relevant subspace the norm of
that projection is also getting larger
and larger
so that it becomes larger than k
and if it becomes sufficiently large say
it's 2k
then what i get is this expression
that the trace inner product is going to
be at least k
and if i look at this indicator times
the probability
that my label is sufficiently large
so it turns out that you can choose tau
to ensure that this trace inner product
is at least k times the probability that
my
my label is sufficiently large
and then that reduces our problem to
really proving
uh sort of uh two things one is that the
probability that the
the um
the label
for a gaussian random input of a relu
network is actually sufficiently large
with some high probability namely that
it's anti-concentrated and also that
when you look
at the corresponding inputs to values
that are sufficiently large the
projection of their norm into the
relevant subspace is also
uh
larger than k
and why is this true
at a very very high level for kind of
two reasons
well three reasons one is that relu
networks are actually piecewise linear
functions this is very well known
um and then uh because you know we have
to look at a bound on the lipschitzness
of this revenue network
uh it's easy to see that lipschitz
functions along a line in gaussian space
are anti-concentrated
so we're a piecewise linear function we
know that linear functions themselves
are anti-concentrated and gaussian space
and so if we apply the law of total
variance we know that there has to be
sort of some piece
within the deep rally network that is
giving us enough anti-concentration for
this analysis to go through
okay so what you can prove is that
you'll actually obtain one relevant
direction by looking at the singular
vectors of this matrix
and
what we were hoping for is that you
could actually just read off all of the
relevant directions from the
decomposition of this matrix
that doesn't happen and so we have to do
something more complicated we actually
need to take that one relevant direction
subtract off
and repeat so what we'd like to do
is
form this new matrix which is the label
y
minus the subtracted off portion
that we just found times x x transpose
minus identity
the problem is that we do we don't know
f
so i don't know how to subtract off this
projection of x into the directions that
we've already found from the label that
we have
and in order to do that we actually need
to brute force search over all possible
functions f
and prove some completeness and sound
this conditions to make sure that this
actually works
so
um yeah so
in order to subtract off the relevant
direction
we need to prove that we can always find
a new direction and that enumerating
over all value networks doesn't hurt us
it turns out that um enumerating over
all of these types of value networks
exactly even that is actually
complicated and we have to work with
approximations to the weight vectors and
the functions themselves
that leads to another level
of complication
[Music]
um and so one of the main structural
facts that we use to get around all of
these technical issues is something from
uh
sort of tropical geometry and that's a
fact about general piecewise continuous
linear functions
they can all and that is that they
always have a max min representation so
if you have a piecewise continuous
function
with m pieces
then i can come up with
uh m subsets
of capital m such that the relu network
or any piecewise continuous linear
function can be written as f of x is the
max over all j and little m the min over
all of my subset subsets i sub j
of these
uh linear functions gi
and it turns out that this structural
fact is what we need to be able to do
sort of the brute force enumeration of
these uh revenue networks in small
dimensional spaces and overcome a lot of
the approximation issues that i
mentioned earlier
okay so to recap we can find one
direction we can use filtered pca on the
differences on the residuals to find the
rest of the directions
and this moves us beyond the csq barrier
of course what's still open because our
algorithm is sort of exponential in the
epsilon parameter is to come up with an
algorithm
uh that's that's polynomial time for
even a constant number of hidden units
and all of the parameters that doesn't
take any of these assumptions about
positivity or bounds on the condition
number of the weight matrices but i
think the more interesting thing
is that we found something that moves
beyond the csq barrier and
potentially suggests some interesting
pre-processing steps before you would
apply your typical optimization
algorithms
um
so we're 12 40 i i didn't completely
finish my talk but i have another hour
so i think we should stop here
i will
for the second hour i'll just finish the
last
handful of slides because they lead into
the second talk anyway um
does that sound okay
guy
okay and i could stop here and take a
couple questions if anyone has this
question
if the number of wi is greater than this
dimension then probably
i'm sorry i'm sorry i'm having trouble
hearing you i'm sorry but the question
is about um
whether you can
what happens when you have more w's than
dimensions
yeah
black corresponds
yeah so it so
one thing you can say in that case
um and this is enumerated this is
discussed i was going to mention this in
this awasti tang the j ragavan paper is
that if the hidden weight vectors
are smooth so if they're chosen at
random
um
then you can apply
uh
you you can still
apply these you can apply a higher order
tensor
decomposition algorithm and still and
things still work out you you pay
um sort of
uh
you pay sort of in the smoothness
parameter not in a fixed fundamental way
but you can say something
thank you
perfect well thanks adam um thanks
everyone we have a short break and we'll
be back
yeah when do you when do you want to
resume guy i mean we started a little
bit late i think ideally
okay